>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Good morning!
>> [Group] Good morning!
>> Lee Ann Potter:
I'm Lee Ann Potter.
I direct educational outreach
here at the Library of Congress
and I am so happy that
all of you are here
for this really terrific event.
How many of you -- and I'm going
to ask you guys to turn that --
dim that light for just a second
so I can see a raise of hands --
how many of you have
ever tried something new?
Yeah, I kind of thought so.
So, you know how when
you try something new,
you're really excited about it
and then sometimes you get a
little bit scared about it?
You know how that is?
Yeah, well that happens to
all of us and here at --
well, let me put it this way.
When you're excited and
even when you're scared,
it always helps to have
somebody who is encouraging you
and somebody who is as
enthusiastic and as excited
as you are about whatever
that new thing is, you know?
And here at the library,
we've been trying a lot
of new things lately.
We want to make sure
that everybody knows
about this amazing library
and its incredible collections
and how much we can learn
here at the library.
And when I say we're trying
a whole bunch of new things,
you know, new things
like maybe, you know,
inviting a superstar
wrestler/actor
to come and read a book.
And fortunately for us, we
have a Librarian of Congress
who shares our excitement
and encourages and leads us
with her energy and
her enthusiasm.
So I am really honored this
morning to be the one who gets
to introduce you to
Dr. Carla Hayden,
the 14th Librarian of Congress.
She earned her PhD at the
University of Chicago.
She began her career as
a children's librarian.
She led the Pratt
Library in Baltimore.
She was the president of the
American Library Association.
And she is absolutely aware
of the power of reading
and the magic of a good
story -- Dr. Hayden.
[ Applause ]
>> Carla Hayden: So
what an exciting day.
You didn't know all that other
stuff that she was saying
when I was here seeing
how you all are.
I am so excited because this
is such a special program.
So I'd like you -- and I got
a chance to meet a lot of you
and I'm supposed to say here, it
says "Please hold your applause
until I introduce
all of the schools."
But let's see how that works.
I do have to ask you, we have
young people that are not here
with us in Washington, DC.
So when we get to them, could
you give them a big hand?
Because from Washington, DC,
right here in the Coolidge
Auditorium, we have students
from Capitol Hill
Montessori School.
[ Applause ]
Bishop John T. Walker
School for Boys.
[ Applause ]
Plummer Elementary
School [applause].
Uh-oh, the excitement is rising.
Kimball Elementary
School [applause].
Langdon Elementary
Murray Elementary
School [applause].
MYSA Micro School [applause].
And, now you right here in
DC, we have to also welcome
and we have students from the
Langley School in McLean -- yay!
And we have students,
like I told you,
from across the country who are
watching us live on Facebook
and YouTube [applause].
So let's give a big Washington,
DC, McLean, Virginia,
welcome to the Calverton School
in Huntingtown, Maryland.
[ Applause ]
The Tinmouth Elementary
School in Tinmouth, Vermont.
[ Applause ]
And the John Dawes
School in Englishtown,
New Jersey [applause].
So welcome, all of you.
As you can imagine, it's an
exciting day here at the Library
of Congress and we have some
more events in the next few days
that you might want
to think about.
On Friday at 10:30, I'm doing a
special story time with the one
and only Paddington Bear.
He will be here in
person -- or in bear --
taking pictures with
children that will be there.
And on Wednesday, next
Wednesday at 11AM,
we're going to have a holiday
story time in the Great Hall
and we will have one menorah
and we're just going
to have a good time.
So we hope that you
will join us.
Now, today, wow!
In September of 1936, the Viking
Press published "The Story
of Ferdinand," written
by Munro Leaf
and illustrated by
Robert Lawson.
And this book became so
popular that, by 1938,
it was already in
its 11th printing.
And today, as I mentioned a
little earlier, we have the son
of Mr. Leaf, Andy Leaf.
So let's give him
a welcome again.
[ Applause ]
And, as I think you
know, later this month,
20th Century Fox will be
releasing a feature-length
animated film based on the book.
And the person who
is joining us today,
actor and wrestling superstar,
Mr. John Cena will be.
[ Applause ]
Will be the voice of Ferdinand.
And today, yes today,
as soon as I leave
and I'm sure you're ready,
he will read the book
and he's going to
talk to us a bit
and you'll have a chance
to ask him questions.
So, as he reads, you'll see
the pages of the book --
not just the pages of any copy
of the book, but the pages
from the original 1936
edition, the actual one
that was submitted to
the Library of Congress
to have a copyright
and it's right here.
You probably know "The Story of
Ferdinand" has been translated
into more than 16
languages and is included
in Time Magazine's 100 Best
Children's Books of All Time.
So it reminds us
that the best version
of yourself means helping
others and that's something
that our special guest today,
Mr. John Cena, does
all the time.
He's actually set the record
for Make-A-Wish granting
with over 500 wishes.
So please join me in welcoming
16-time world champion wrestler,
five-time US champion wrestler,
record-setting Make-A-Wish
grantor,
star of blockbuster
movies, the man you're here
to see, Mr. John Cena.
[ Applause ]
Whoa!
>> John Cena: Look
at this place!
[ Applause ]
Thank you very much [applause].
What a special day!
I'm going to put my 1938
edition Ferdinand next
to the first print 1936 edition.
We're going to look at the
1936 edition but not touch it.
It's very, very delicate
and very important.
And the people from the Library
of Congress were very thorough
in saying like, hey, don't
touch the first book.
[laughter] So I'm going
to oblige their wishes
and we're going to
do this thing.
I'm very, very excited
to be here today.
I'd like to first thank the
Leaf family for allowing me
to be a part of something
like this, because certainly
without the creation
of the story
of Ferdinand I wouldn't be
here reading to you today.
So it's a great honor and I'm
very grateful to be chosen
as Ferdinand for the
movie that's coming out.
But it all starts with
the very famous story.
This story has a very important
and a very powerful message.
And the book has
been in publication
for over 80 years now.
That means this book is
twice as old as I am.
[laughter] But I think,
I think the reason
that the message continually
gets sent and absorbed year
after year is because
it's very easy to digest.
Ferdinand is such a large bull
that people think he's
one thing, but the advent
of him loving flowers
humanizes him.
And you realize that what you
see isn't always what you get.
It's a very important story and
certainly a story that's close
to my heart, as the life
that you see that live
on WW Television mirrors kind
of the story of Ferdinand.
I go through a lot of pressure
every day to change who I am.
And there's a lot of folks
using some negative influence
out there to try to make
me change my values.
But it just makes me stand
up and be proud of who I am
and be proud of those values.
And not change to try
to please someone else.
Just be proud of who I am.
So with that said, we've got
an excellent story today.
I'm going to read and they
said I was going to talk
after I read, but I've
already switched it up.
I've already talked because I
want you to have as much time
as you can for questions
afterwards.
So I look forward
to hearing from you
after we hear from this.
Shall we? [clears throat].
"The Story of Ferdinand."
This is my loan agreement
from the Library
of Congress [laughter].
I promised to return this book,
the penalty is quite heavy.
Once upon a time in Spain,
there was a little bull,
and his name was Ferdinand.
All the other little bulls
he lived with run, jump,
and butt their heads together.
But not Ferdinand.
He liked to just sit quietly
and [sniffs] smell the flowers.
He had a favorite spot out in
the pasture, under a cork tree.
It was his favorite tree, and he
would sit in its shade all day
and [sniffs] smell the flowers.
Sometimes his mother, who was
a cow, would worry about him.
She was afraid he would be
lonesome and all by himself.
Why don't you run and play with
the other little bulls, skip,
and butt your head,
she would say.
And Ferdinand would
shake his head.
I like it better here where
I can just sit quietly
and smell the flowers.
His mother saw that
he was not lonesome.
And because she was an
understanding mother,
even though she was a cow,
she let him just sit
there and be happy.
As the years went by,
Ferdinand grew and grew,
until he was very
big and very strong.
All the other bulls who
had grown up with him
in the same pasture would
fight each other all day.
They would butt each other
and stick each other
with their horns.
What they wanted most of all
was to be picked to fight
in the bullfights in Madrid.
But not Ferdinand.
He still liked to
just sit quietly
under the cork tree,
smell the flowers.
One day, five men came in very
funny hats to pick the biggest,
fastest, roughest bull to fight
in the bullfights in Madrid.
All the other bulls ran around
snorting and butting, leaping
and jumping so the men would
think that they were very,
very strong and fierce,
and pick them.
Ferdinand knew that
they wouldn't pick him
and he didn't care.
So he went out to his
favorite cork tree to sit down.
He didn't look where he was
sitting, and instead of sitting
in the nice cool grass in the
shade, he sat on a bumblebee.
Well, if you were a
bumblebee and a bull sat
on you, what would you do?
You would sting him.
And that's exactly what
this bee did to Ferdinand.
Wow, did it hurt!
Ferdinand jumped
up with a snort.
He ran around puffing and
snorting, butting and pawing
on the ground as
if he were crazy.
The five men saw him and
they all shouted with joy.
Here was the largest and
fiercest bull of all!
Just the one bull for
the fights in Madrid!
So they took him away for
the bullfight day in a cart.
And what a day it was.
Flags were flying.
Bands were playing.
All the lovely ladies had
flowers in their hair.
They had a parade
into the bullring.
First came the bandoleros with
long sharp pins with ribbons
on them to stick the
bull and make him mad.
Next came the picadores,
who rode skinny horses
and they had long
spears to stick the bull
and make him even madder.
Then came the matador,
the proudest of all.
He thought he was very handsome
and bowed to the ladies.
He had a red cape and a
sword and was supposed
to stick the bull last of all.
Then came the bull.
And you know who
that was, don't you?
Ferdinand!
They called him Ferdinand
the fierce.
And all the bandoleros
were afraid of him.
And the picadors
And the matador was
scared stiff.
Ferdinand ran into the
middle of the ring.
And everyone shouted
and clapped,
because they thought he was
going to fight fiercely and butt
and snort and stick
his horns around.
But not Ferdinand.
When he got to the middle of
the ring, he saw the flowers
in all the lovely ladies'
hair and he just sat
down and quietly smelled.
He wouldn't fight and be
fierce no matter what they did.
He just sat [sniffs]
and smelled.
The bandoleros were mad and
the picadors were madder
and the matador was
so mad that he cried,
because he couldn't show
off with his cape and sword.
So they had to take
Ferdinand home.
And for all I know, he
is sitting there still
under his favorite cork tree,
[sniffs] smelling the
flowers just quietly.
And he is very happy.
The end.
[ Applause ]
What a cool story and
what an important message.
Being different's okay.
We're not all alike.
And we should be proud
that even if you look
around this audience,
we're all different.
And we should be
okay being different.
Because even if you're
different like Ferdinand and you
like to [sniffs]
smell the flowers,
as long as you're
happy, that's cool.
Thank you guys for listening
to a wonderful story.
And if you guys have
any questions
for me, now is the time.
So fire away.
Ooh, lots of questions,
this is excellent.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Okay,
guys, the way we're going
to do the questions is
I have four colleagues
that are stationed.
Right over here is Abby.
Over here is Catherine.
Over here is Sasha.
And I've got a mic.
So we're going to
sort of work the room.
I'll start with the
first question down here,
and I'm going to throw
it over there to Abby
and then we're just going to
make a big ole circle, okay.
So how about you right here?
And I'm not going to hand you
the mic, I'm going to hold it.
I need you to speak
really clearly.
And the deal here is we're
asking questions, okay.
So you can't just
say, oh, I love you.
You can't do that, okay?
It's got to be questions,
all right?
Okay.
>> John Cena: All
righty, here we go.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Stand up
and you can say your name.
>> My name is Adrian.
And can you tell me how
you and Ferdinand connect?
>> John Cena: Oh, yeah,
that's a good question.
So how do Ferdinand
and I connect?
Well, Ferdinand is
misunderstood.
People think because
he looks some way
that he should be something.
And a lot of times in WWE
I'm very misunderstood.
There's a lot of people out
there chanting at the top
of their lungs for
me to do something
that I really don't want to do.
But just like Ferdinand,
I make sure I stand proud
to what I believe
in and I'm happy.
>> When you were born, did you
want to do what Ferdinand did,
or you wanted to be a wrestler?
>> John Cena: Say again.
>> When you were first born,
did you want to be a wrestler,
or just do what Ferdinand did?
>> John Cena: That's
a great question.
So when I was first
born, my eyes opened
and I was like, what's going on?
[laughter] Wow, this
place is weird
and I can't even move my
hands or hold my head up.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
As a younger person,
I was very attracted
and taken aback by WWE.
Because I have an imagination,
just like all you guys.
And man these WWE wrestlers
really spoke to my imagination.
They were larger than life and
doing these amazing things.
And I said to myself as a young
person one day I would really
like to be a world champion.
And here I am, a
16-time world champion.
Now, that does mean that
I've lost it 16 times.
But I've done okay.
>> What inspired you
to be in this book?
>> John Cena: Oh, well,
the story is very special.
And it's been in
publication for over 80 years.
And I think when you read it,
just like we all listened,
even though sometimes
the words can get old,
it never gets misunderstood.
And I think the message
is really cool.
And I was very happy to partner
up with the folks
making the movie.
The animators that made
the movie are very gifted.
And once you guys see the movie,
I think you're all
going to agree.
It was a great thing
to be a part of.
I think you guys are
all going to enjoy it.
>> Before we go to my friend
over here, I have a question
from one of the kids
in the school that's
watching over livestream.
>> John Cena: Thank you
guys on the Internet.
Hey.
>> The name of the
student is Trevor.
He's in fourth grade
at the Calverton School
in Huntingtown, Maryland.
And his question is: Dear John
Cena, why do you do what you do?
Do you really enjoy it?
Or do you ever wish
to do something else?
>> John Cena: No.
So this is a very important
message from Ferdinand.
And if I could leave you with
one bit of information --
I know we're going
to talk a lot today
so sometimes your attention
span's going to go away.
You may want to look at
your phone or something.
Take this with you.
I promise you, you've got
a long road ahead of each
and every one of you out there.
Make sure you do what you love.
Because you asked if I would
want to do anything else, no.
I want to be right
here right now with all
of you reading a
wonderful story,
preparing to release a
wonderful movie to the world.
And then hopefully if I get
what I want for Christmas,
go back to my WWE family
and do what I love.
So it's okay through life,
you're going to have pressures
around you of people trying
to make you do certain things.
If you do what you love
you'll never call it work.
Because right now we're
having fun and it ain't work.
So I'm doing exactly
what I'd like to do.
That's a great question.
>> My name is Mekla.
And I wonder, do you
like being in the ring?
>> John Cena: Do I
>> Yeah.
>> John Cena: When I'm
doing well [laughter].
There aren't -- I mean,
it's all so exciting.
The crowd noise is fantastic
and the lights are amazing
and the fans are great.
But there are those times
when you let's say
finish second place,
and those are tough times.
But it keeps you wanting to get
better and come back for more.
>> I'm Jay.
And one question -- well,
actually two questions.
>> John Cena: Two-parter,
excellent.
>> What's your favorite
book as a kid?
>> John Cena: What's that?
>> What's your favorite
book as a kid?
>> John Cena: My favorite
book as a kid was called "Cars
and Trucks and Things That Go."
[laughter].
>> Wow!
>> John Cena: I'll give you
a spoiler alert on to why
that was my favorite book.
Because I love cars and trucks
and things that go [laughter].
Okay, second part?
>> And what's your favorite
thing to do on SmackDown Live?
>> John Cena: What's that?
>> What's your favorite thing
to do on SmackDown Live?
>> John Cena: Ooh, I think
the easiest way to put
that is be a part
of SmackDown Live.
Because folks like you
are entertained by it.
So thank you.
Two good questions.
>> Is it hard being a wrestler
and being an actor
at the same time?
>> John Cena: Ooh, no.
Because you just get
to be imaginative.
You get to create and
you get to have fun.
And it's tough, it's
a lot of hard work,
but it's really fun to do both.
Good question.
>> My name is Jimar.
And I want to know when
you start your career?
>> John Cena: Will?
>> Started your career.
>> John Cena: I'm
sorry, say again.
>> When did you start
your career?
>> John Cena: Oh,
when did I start.
I'll answer that
question with a question.
How old are you?
>> Nine.
>> John Cena: It might've been
well before you were born.
So it's been a while,
it's been a while.
I started my career
in 2002 on television,
so it's been about 15 years.
I see a lot of hands,
this is great.
>> Lee Ann Potter: We have a
question also from our friends
who are watching remotely.
And this one's from
a fourth grader
in Clarendon Elementary School.
Did you listen to
the story as a child?
And did you relate to it then?
>> John Cena: Well, as a child
I knew of this story and growing
up I knew of this story.
But amazingly enough, the first
time I actually read the book
from cover to cover
was for this.
And it was because I wanted
to make sure it was
really important
to send a message of Ferdinand.
So like you guys, I'm being
introduced to such a famous book
and I can see now why it's
been around for so long
and touched so many generations.
>> Did you like acting with
people like Peyton Manning?
>> John Cena: Well, I was very
thankful that I didn't have
to play football
against Peyton Manning.
But yes, he was very
funny and goofy
and I thought he did an
excellent job in the movie.
>> My name's Xavier.
Was you ever scared when
you first got in the ring?
>> John Cena: Was I ever scared
when I first got in the ring.
I'm scared all the time.
I was scared behind the door to
come out and talk to you guys.
But it's your ability
to understand
that you're doing something
awesome and you're going
to be nervous and you're going
to doubt yourself at times,
just like when I'm in the ring.
But that's kind of
what life is about.
It's kind of overcoming
your fears and being able
to take chances to
do some cool stuff.
So yes, I was nervous.
I'm always nervous.
But I always do my best to
just go out there anyway.
>> What was your
favorite sport before WWE?
>> John Cena: What is my?
>> Favorite sport
before the WWE?
>> John Cena: Say
again, I'm sorry.
>> What was your
favorite sport before WWE?
>> John Cena: Favorite
sport before WWE.
Well, I played football
in high school
and I played football
in college.
So I'll have to say football.
>> My name is Casia
and I'm in first grade.
Ferdinand likes to
look at flowers.
What do you like to do?
>> John Cena: Say again.
>> My name is Casia
and I'm in first grade.
Ferdinand likes to
look at flowers.
What do you like to do?
>> John Cena: Ooh, okay.
So Ferdinand likes flowers.
What do I like to do.
I also like flowers.
My favorite flower is the rose.
And a little known
fact about me.
When sometimes I've
had a stressful day
or a stressful week, I actually
like to sit and relax and,
just like Ferdinand,
[sniffs] smell the flowers.
>> Lee Ann Potter: We
have another question
from somebody who's
watching live.
And this time they're asking
a question via Twitter.
It's from somebody
called @JohnCenaCrew,
so maybe they're a fan.
If you were to do
another animated movie,
what character would
you like to voice?
>> John Cena: You know, the
animated universe is great
because you can start with
nothing, or you can start
with a short story, and
build a universe around it.
So I guess it all depends on
the powerful subject matter.
This was easy.
They asked me if I wanted to
be Ferdinand and I was in.
Because the subject
matter is great.
And I knew the people
making the movie were great.
So I knew they would
create a wonderful universe.
So I don't know, hopefully
I get to do it again,
and we'll see what happens.
>> My name is Maximo.
Would you like to continue
your wrestling streak
or just smell the flowers?
[laughter.]
>> John Cena: Well, man,
one is a little bit less
physically demanding.
So there are times when I'd
rather smell the flowers,
but I really do like
being able to perform
for audiences, as you can tell.
I really enjoy being
here with you guys.
And there's nothing
more exciting
than being in a WW ring.
So I think I'm going
to go with that one.
These are all great
questions, by the way.
>> My name is Nilo.
What is your favorite part
in the story of Ferdinand?
>> John Cena: Okay,
that's a good question.
I was peculiar why the
five men had funny hats.
Because if you look
at the picture,
they do have really,
really funny hats.
And in the story I think
that's a nice little detail
that the men had funny hats.
But my favorite part
is when Ferdinand runs
out into the middle of the arena
and everybody thinks he's going
to fight really fierce.
And it's because he sees all
the flowers and it reminds him
of home, he sits down
and is just enjoyably
happy smelling the flowers.
>> What do people often think
about you which is wrong?
>> John Cena: Oh, okay,
that's a great question.
What do people often think
about me which is wrong.
That I always kind of like to
be what you see on television.
I truly enjoy my
time in the WWE,
but I also enjoy a
lot of other stuff.
And even if some people think
it doesn't make me look cool
or seem tough, it doesn't
mean that I don't enjoy it.
So I guess people think I'm
a big tough guy all the time,
and that's wrong.
>> My name is Lela.
I wanted to know how you think
you would be the best part
as Ferdinand when you
two are so different?
>> John Cena: Say again.
>> How would you think
you were the best part
as Ferdinand in the movie?
>> John Cena: Oh, okay.
So this is going to sound weird.
I think the best part
in Ferdinand the movie is
played by the calming goat.
Now here I am, I'm Ferdinand.
So I mean, this is great.
But my favorite character,
when you see the movie,
is a calming goat named Lupe.
And when Lupe shows up,
you'll understand why.
So that's my favorite character.
>> Lee Ann Potter: This is a
question from Cameron who's
in the fifth grade at the
Calverton School in Huntingtown.
How would you explain
why reading is
so important for children?
>> John Cena: Well, what
a wonderful building to be
in to answer that question.
There is a small hallway
with a tile fixture
that is extremely small
above one of the arches,
that in brilliantly
laid tile simply says,
"knowledge is power."
And that couldn't
be more correct.
And in a place with
almost unlimited knowledge
as the books keep pouring in and
the materials keep pouring in,
it's certainly important to
be sharp and be educated.
Because with knowledge
comes power.
So that is why reading
is important.
>> My name is Emily.
And how long was auditioning?
>> John Cena: Whew,
man, it was tough.
They had me talk a lot.
No, I'm just kidding.
It was very, very fun.
Because amazingly enough,
the people that animate,
the people that draw,
they're like big kids.
They're so fun to be
around, because they want
to make these crazy
things and these wild
and imaginative things happen.
So the audition was easy
because I'm like a big kid too.
So we just kind of hit it off.
And we were like, well, so are
we going to make this movie?
And they're like, yeah,
let's make this movie.
And we did it.
>> Why did you want
to be Ferdinand?
>> John Cena: Well, I think
Ferdinand's really cool.
Because in the book, you
can see that he doesn't want
to do what the other bulls do.
And like his mom
worries about him a lot.
But once she takes the time
to talk with Ferdinand,
she then is like, no,
he's going be okay.
So I think it's really
important that even
if you do something
different that a ton
of people don't do even when
they're pressuring you to do it,
it doesn't mean you
can't be happy.
So I thought that
was a pretty fun
and important message to send.
>> My name is Alex.
And who's your enemy in WWE?
>> John Cena: Well,
there's an old saying
that you are your
own worst enemy.
So it's probably
me at sometimes.
You know, I don't really have
any archenemies I would say.
It's really just a very
competitive environment
where we all want
to be champion.
So I guess when me
giving you that answer,
whoever is the champion.
>> My name is Jayden.
And who is your wrestler
in the WWE?
>> John Cena: My favorite
wrestler of all time,
that's a good question.
I know when I was your age,
I really liked Hulk Hogan,
because I thought he was
like larger-than-life
and a superhero.
Now it is, hmm, this is
going to sound weird,
I would say my favorite
of all time is a tie
between two people.
One, Vince McMahon,
because I think he's one
of the greatest performers
ever in WWE.
Two, and I would say a
tie, I would say a tie,
is The Rock [applause].
He's just got an
electricity like no other.
And the eyebrow thing,
I can't do it.
[laughter].
>> Hi. My name's Naomi.
And I want to ask, do
you do your own stunts?
>> John Cena: Do I
do my own stunts.
Actually, it's a very elaborate
process when we film a WW event,
that I do all the
talky-talky, and then right
when we have a chance to do
action, we stop and a guy
who looks like me comes in and
does my own stunts [laughter].
It would be easier if we just
did -- yes, I do my own stunts.
I knew that one wasn't
going to hold
up for more than two seconds.
>> Lee Ann Potter: A question
from online from Summer,
fourth grader in
Clarendon Elementary.
What do you imagine
yourself doing in 10 years?
>> John Cena: I just hope that
I can continue to tell stories
and actually call it work.
This is the greatest
thing to be able to do,
to be able to work hard,
but at the end of the day,
something that you love.
So if 10 years from now I can
continue to keep doing this,
it's going to be great.
So hopefully I can.
>> My name is Charlotte.
And my brother loves your story.
>> John Cena: Well,
thank you very much.
[laughter].
Thank you.
You know, it was about time
we had a statement instead
of a question.
And that was a very good
one, it was a very good one.
>> My name is Devon.
And why did you quit WWE?
Why did you quit WWE?
>> John Cena: That's
a good question.
I don't why anybody
would quit WWE.
I mean, I'm just going to give
you a little spoiler alert.
I'm still there.
So here's the thing,
here's the lowdown.
Very interesting question,
because I'm not there right now.
So what happens is -- so I've
got this full-time job with WWE.
And then the phone rings
and somebody's like, hey,
man, you want another job?
And I say, well, yeah, but
like I can't let this one go.
And they're like,
well, that's cool,
just take a little break
and then come back.
I'm like, whoa, really?
And they're like yeah.
And I'm like, all right, cool.
So I'm kind of doing
two jobs at once.
>> So my name is Rashard.
I was thinking, as
soon as you were a kid,
did you ever think you were
going to make it in the WWE?
>> John Cena: Not for a second.
I looked at those
WWE superstars.
I was like, man, there's no
way I could ever do that.
But that was when
I was a little kid.
I always kept it my mind
that if I worked hard
that maybe I'd have a chance.
And when I got a chance, I
wasn't a superstar overnight.
It was a lot of -- I
swung and missed a lot.
But through hard work and not
giving up, I eventually --
it took a very long time,
but I eventually
became a WWE superstar.
But as a young kid I
didn't think I'd make it.
>> My name is Hanas and
I've got a question.
How do you make a
connection with Ferdinand?
>> John Cena: How do I make
a connection with Ferdinand?
Well, here's the cool
thing about Ferdinand.
I think everybody in this
room can make a connection
with Ferdinand.
Because we all interact
with a bunch
of people every day,
if you look around.
We all can look around in the
room and everybody's different.
And at one point or
another, probably everybody
in this room has
been misunderstood.
And if you've been misunderstood
for even one second,
whether you know it or not,
you have a connection
with Ferdinand.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
This is the question
from Devon, a fifth grader.
What children's book
did you enjoy as a child
that touched your
heart like Ferdinand?
>> John Cena: Well, we've talked
about the mechanical obsession
that I had as a young kid.
I'll even say again that aside
from "Cars and Trucks and Things
That Go," I also
gravitated towards a lot
of the works of Dr. Seuss.
I thought Dr. Seuss was a
wonderful way of telling stories
and his worlds were so
bizarre and imaginative,
that as a kid I really
gravitated toward Dr. Seuss
as well.
>> My name is Delaney.
Do you know why they decided
to film Ferdinand this year?
>> John Cena: Why they decided
to make Ferdinand this year.
Well, believe it or not, the
guy who directed Ferdinand,
the studio that made
Ferdinand, started on this move
in 2010, seven years ago.
So it took seven years
to make the movie.
And why they waited till
2010, I have no idea.
This is also a fact
about the movie.
It was an animated movie
way back in the day.
It was about six minutes long.
And it very, very well-received.
It won a bunch of awards.
So I think maybe because it
already was a shorter animated
movie is why they waited so long
to make it a big animated movie.
>> My name is Neoni.
And I want to know, do you
think you will carry a legacy?
>> John Cena: Do I think?
>> You will carry a legacy?
>> John Cena: Do I think
I'll carry a legacy?
>> Yeah.
>> John Cena: That's
for you guys to decide.
It's okay.
Whether I do or not,
I'm having a fun time
and I'm doing what I enjoy,
and that's most important.
>> My name is Kumani.
And what's the hardest
challenge or struggle you faced?
>> John Cena: Not
enough hours in the day.
Like I want to be able
to do all this cool stuff
and then the day just runs out.
So maybe if there was a
little more time in the day,
I could be able to
do more fun stuff.
But for the most part,
it's all pretty cool,
just not enough time.
>> Hi. My name is Tyree.
What do you practice at for WWE?
>> John Cena: Well, I practice
at my trash talk [laughter].
Keep that real sharp, just
in case somebody trash
talks against you.
Practice on my fitness.
Make sure I'm real strong.
Because sometimes
you've got to be strong.
And one more thing, and this
is something I practice on --
and you guys can watch WWE
and know that I'm not kidding.
I practice on my tolerance.
Because the audience is
everybody from around the world,
and there are some groups
of the audience that like me
and there are some groups of
the audience that don't like me.
And when those groups that
don't like me yell really,
really loud that I'm not any
good, I don't turn around
and say, hey, you
can't say that.
Because they can say that.
So it's actually,
believe it or not,
my time in the WWE has made
me have a greater appreciation
for all of you out there.
So that's the thing I
practice the most is tolerance.
>> Lee Ann Potter: A
question from Charlie
who is a fourth grader.
How did you come up with the
phrase, "you can't see me"?
>> John Cena: Ooh,
how did I come
up with the phrase,
"you can't see me"?
So I can't take credit for it.
My youngest brother Sean -- who
doesn't go by the name Sean.
We call him Boog.
So my youngest brother Boog
dared me to do it on television.
The very first time I played
him my theme song, he heard it
and he was like, man, that's
awesome and he started dancing
and he started doing
something like this.
And I was like, you
look ridiculous.
He's like, ridiculous enough
for you to do it on TV?
And I said, of course.
And back then, nobody
watched my matches,
so I didn't think anybody
was paying attention.
So right away I got a guy
down and "you can't see me."
And now I've been
doing it for 15 years.
And nobody can actually see me.
I'm actually really invisible.
It's quite fascinating.
>> My name is Lilly.
And my question is, how do
you get into starting --
like how did you like -- why
did you want to start wrestling?
>> John Cena: So I
wanted to start wrestling
because I've always
been pretty strong.
I've always been in
pretty good shape.
And I really, really,
really enjoy it.
I like to watch the programs.
I like to keep up
on the superstars.
It's something that I enjoy
even though I'm not involved.
So it's essentially
like a dream come true.
>> My name is Jackson.
And I wonder if you ever got
bullied at school before?
>> John Cena: Oh,
yes, yes I did.
Not only in school, and as a
young man I was bullied a lot.
Because I didn't look
like everybody else.
Because I didn't talk
And it was some very
difficult times.
Bullying is very
difficult to deal with.
But here's the thing.
I get bullied every day, with
the advent of social media
and everyone that can
comment on your page.
A lot of people tell me that
I'm really not any good.
I've been called
pretty much everything.
But like I said, my
experience with all you guys
over the years has
taught me great tolerance.
And the best advice I can
give you after all that,
just don't pay it any mind.
Certainly tell someone about it.
But don't sweat it.
Those people really are just
wasting their time anyway.
And chances are more often
than not, they're going
through some issues that
they can't really deal with.
So yes, I was bullied
then, I'm bullied now,
but I don't pay it
any mind at all.
>> Hi. My name is Wyndom.
And do you like doing
animated movies or movies
like the Fred movies more?
>> John Cena: So I like
doing animated movies,
because I'm not very
animated with my own body.
Kidding. I enjoy both.
And everyone often asks me,
well, what do you like more,
WWE or movies or do you
like animated movies
or doing the Fred movies?
It's simply the ability to
create and tell a story.
It's like one day painting
in paints and then the next
with pen and then
the next with crayon.
You still get to
make art or clay
but it's just different forms.
>> Have you ever had a
dream that you accomplished?
>> John Cena: Have I
ever had a dream that?
>> You accomplished?
>> John Cena: Ooh, I
mean, every single day.
I'm able to live a
dream every single day.
Although I have this
one weird dream.
But no, I'll talk about that
later, that's okay [laughter].
>> Lee Ann Potter:
This is a question
from Robert, fifth grader.
As a kid did you ever
get your peer-pressured?
And if so, what did you do?
If you saw someone else being
teased, what did you do?
>> John Cena: You know, I was
peer-pressured a lot as a kid.
I mean, I think I'm
peer-pressured now
as an adult as well.
And we all are, guys.
You know, we go to school
with a bunch of people
and there are groups of kids
that maybe we want to be with
that maybe we don't
mesh so well with.
And we always kind of try
to find out who we are
and where we we're
going to go in life.
And sometimes we let people
make those decisions for us.
And every single time I've let
those folks make a decision
for me, it has really
wound up disastrous.
So I guess my advice
when it comes
to peer pressure is just
listen to everything around you
and be aware of everything
around you
but make your own choice.
Because then at least
you'll be happy with it
at the end of the day.
>> My name is SJ.
And can you do 1000 push-ups?
[laughter].
>> John Cena: I can.
I can easily do 1000
push-ups if I start now
and end in 2020 [laughter].
But I'm not going to start now.
We're just going to speculate
that I can do the 1000 push-ups.
>> Lee Ann Potter: All right.
We're going to take one
last round of questions.
So this is my last question here
and then we'll head over there,
there, and back, okay?
>> My name is Wesley.
And what does it feel
like to be a role model
out of the ring and in the ring?
>> John Cena: That's
very kind words.
I think that's a -- I
owe you a thank you, sir.
That means -- for someone
like you to say that means you
and a bunch of people around you
are actually paying attention
to what I do and you
absorb the message I send.
And it means more than you know.
So I mean it when
I say thank you.
That's very cool of you.
>> Hi. My name is Nigel Porter
and I'm in the fifth grade.
When did you think that
you were very famous?
>> John Cena: When did I
find out I was very talented?
>> Yes.
>> John Cena: Oh, so
you're saying I'm talented?
I think we just became
best buds.
Thank you so much.
I don't know, man.
I just -- I try to
work really hard
and do the best I can
every time I get a chance,
but I'm still looking
for that talent.
Maybe one day I'll find it.
>> My name is Angela.
What is your favorite thing
in the whole wide world?
>> John Cena: Favorite thing
in the whole wide world besides
ice cream and pizza, you ask?
Hmm, that's a great question.
I love making people happy, man.
It's a really good
feeling when you can --
when you can do something and
put a smile on somebody's face.
I guess that's why I do
all the stuff that I do.
I really like making
people happy.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
This is a question
from Cameron in fifth grade.
Did you have a childhood
nickname
and how did it make you feel?
>> John Cena: Yeah,
so my childhood nickname
was John Cena.
Which, in the world of WWE,
with these awesome performers
like Stone Cold and Hulk Hogan
and The Rock and The Undertaker,
they just wanted
to use my nickname.
So I'm John Cena [laughter].
I should have planned
that one better.
>> Lee Ann Potter: And
the very last question.
>> My name is Antoinette.
And could you could how
many matches you've won?
>> John Cena: Say it again?
>> Could you count how
many matches you've won?
>> How many matches you won.
>> John Cena: Could
I -- I'm sorry, what?
>> How many matches
you have won.
>> John Cena: Oh, how
many matches have I won?
Well, I've won at least 16
because I have 16 championships.
[ Applause ]
And just keep in mind,
in the whole winning
and losing thing -- in baseball,
if you only get a hit
three times out of 10,
you go into the Hall of Fame.
So kind of -- if you go by
that model, I'm doing okay.
>> Lee Ann Potter: All right.
You guys, your questions
were absolutely fabulous.
Let's give him one
more round [applause].
>> John Cena: Thank
you, everybody.
[ Applause ]
I just want to say thanks,
not only for your questions
but for everybody being patient.
And although I am here now, I'm
going to step over there so,
legitimately, in the count
of three, you can't see me.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.GOV.